it's Veronica's opening night but the
town is still full of fright let's say
cheers to a great episode on Sweetwater
secrets oh my goodness River babes we
have so much to discuss
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 303 chapter 38 as above so below
today I'm bringing you exclusive
interviews with matron amick and Lily
Reinhart discussing two of the episodes
most sultry and shocking moments and
then we're unleashing hisses and kisses
so start commenting below with your
thoughts holy hell that was a lot that
happened in tonight's episode so let's
power through it all in the blue and
gold breakdown okay so the episode
started off with a three-week time drum
our Cheeseman stuck in solitary
confinement
Veronica's been up to her pearls and
bills and thousand bug head have been
doing well they've been doing this let's
start off with our chief turns out the
warden has been running a secret inmate
Fight Club and there's nothing he loves
more than to watch underage boys beat
the crap out of each other he's vile
that kid is a star
Archie eventually discovers that the
best way to get out of this bad
situation is to put on a show and then
plot a not-so-secret plan
we're escaping and underneath pops
Veronica speakeasy is officially open
cheers girl okay so it's actually called
this la bonne nuit but I have no idea
what she said there so I'm not even
gonna try and I'm just gonna keep
calling it V's speakeasy of course we're
calling it a speakeasy
but before opening night both penny
Peabody and Sharaf Minetta showed up and
tried to blackmail her with vicious
threats and a whole lot of drugs
clearly this had Hiram's pathetic stamp
all over it so the enlisted Shoney's
helped to do a little blackmailing of
her own opening night was a big success
and everyone looked to die for so really
that's all that matters oh my god
obsessed with that guy speaking of death
Betty and Jughead are still on the case
of the gargoyle King so they decided to
split up to cover more ground
Betty decided to try and get close to
Evelyn ever never and pretend she was
actually interested in the farm but she
quickly discovered that her mother has
told this brainwash group about every
single dark secret they had ever had
wait what what mom jug had followed
Ethel into the bunker to play his first
game of Griffin's and gargoyles he
tempted his own fate and then had to use
those blue lips to smooch princess
ethylene in order to get the gene jiwu
book then for some reason Ethel drank
the poisoned Cup awkwardly flirted with
Jughead in the hospital and told The
Gargoyle King that she put a copy of the
G&G rule book and every locker at
Riverdale high goodness gracious I can't
take that thing seriously so let's
switch gears to the most swoon worthy
moments of the night and seven seconds
in heaven you guys it was the moment
we've been waiting all summer for FPE
Alice's bedroom rendezvous finally
happened and it was sultry and sweet and
way too short I know you all wanted more
so here's some behind-the-scenes secrets
from matron Amick about what it was like
to film this moment whiskey orange take
a look phallus broke the internet with
the season 3 trailer yeah point 1 sec I
know right that people just pause that
pause yep everywhere I saw every frame
the screen grabbed and retweeted I think
I talked to roberto about it and he said
that together you and skeet had so much
fun filming that and that they were like
remember you are supposed to be talking
about things that everything you guys
were doing together was just so
undeniably sexy yeah yeah it was funny
because it was written you know it's a
little bit after the fact a little
post-coital as we like to say but and
then the the what we're speaking about
is you know kind of heavy right so we
were sort of like hmm how do we like
give the fans what they want which is
something sexy but then go straight into
something that's a little uncomfortable
to talk about so I think we navigated it
all right yeah but as much as I enjoyed
watching these two hot Riverdale parents
sharing some alone time together
something about it also left me feeling
very unsettled
maybe it was them crediting the farm for
Alice's sexual awakening or it could
have been that they were talking about
two dead teens or maybe it was the fact
that they were discussing their kids who
are also dating while still in bed
together all I know is that the cherry
on top of this awkward sundae were these
side-by-side moments what are you
thinking about Alice
don't get me wrong you guys I love
phallus and I love bug head but I need a
buffer there's something about seeing
them one right after the other that
makes me cringe just a little also the
fact that bug head has hijacked Dilton
flare as their own private sex bunker is
sweet I guess too bad for Betty that
Jughead was forced to share a smooch
with Ethel but something tells me she'll
understand
as for Shoni we were treated to quite a
few cuddles an epic serpent photo shoot
and C T and V put on their cat suits for
an amazing drug hunting mission that was
pretty much it can you believe it's been
three episodes of season three and we
haven't even had a show knee kiss I
don't know what to say anymore so I'm
going to channel all my rage into hisses
and kisses my first and biggest hits of
the night is going to warden whatever
your name is
congratulations you disgusting excuse of
a human being who gets his kicks from
watching boys beat the hell out of each
other
I hate you more than hiram chick and a
black hood combined sexually I'm not
even mad that's amazing hisses -
princess ethylene for blackmailing a
kiss from Jughead trying to poison
herself and to happily worshipping that
thing in the hospital room be honest
river babes who else laughed out loud
just a little when it raised its little
Twiggy t-rex arms hmm physics it the
intense blue dye that's staining
everyone's lips what is in those cups
y'all need to start brushing your teeth
better um excuse you hisses - the
Riverdale parents for not telling the
kids about their G&G pass this game is
it's pure evil and hisses - Evelyn ever
never and her father Edgar for spreading
their weird culture
crapped through the Cooper family like a
cancer pollen creeps me out take a look
at what Lily Reinhard had to tell me
about this shape a new character so we
know there's not magic but we do know
that the farm is here and it is very
real are you located - oh yeah we meet
Evelyn in episode 3 Oh - yes and she's a
little haunting oh yeah best way that I
can describe her what can you tease
about she's just seems to be lurking
around them yeah lurking yeah she's like
her shadow yes
I think she's this strange question mark
that is all of a sudden in Riverdale
Betty is obviously very suspicious of
the farm to begin with and then this
girl who's so very connected to the farm
comes into the picture and so you know
and all these weird awful things are
happening in the town just as the farm
has come in has come into town yeah so
it's kind of like not a coincidence in
Evelyn is just very creepy and like
Spacey and like I don't know she's she's
kita kita in on Betty because she knows
Betty is a non-believer an unbeliever
and we'll get to the bottom of things
so you're the biggest threat in town
yeah so I think everyone kinda like I
try to butter me up and my new over
somehow but also like if she's not
believing her mother and sister that
some random strangers not gonna help ya
know yeah it's gonna I think push her a
little further away kisses - Veronica
for being a successful business owner
and realizing that Sheryl and Tony are
two influential Queens who get ish done
go on
kisses des Joaquin cuz he seems like he
definitely needs some and kisses to us
finally getting a sweet B&B friendship
moment I've missed those ladies kisses -
Josie's a first solo performance obut
hisses - those weird shadow dancers in
the background they were very
distracting kisses - everyone's sparkly
speakeasy looks I decided to dress up -
and to the fact that so much has already
happened and we're only three episodes
into season three now
keep up the momentum you guys
I was hoping you'd say that and that's
all I have for you now check back with
me next time for our Sweetwater secrets
preview for episode 304 The Midnight
Club because guess what I was on set for
that episode and I'll be bringing you
exclusive chats with Mark Consuelos and
his real-life son Michael who will be
playing young Hyrum in the flashbacks
but for now hit subscribe please give
this video like and then let it all out
in the comments
what were your top hisses and kisses of
episode 303 do you think that phallus
and the bug had sex scenes were a little
weird has Ethel completely lost it and
does anyone else love to hate Evelyn
ever never tell me and I'll talk to you
soon river babes Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]